thanks Brian for doing this I really
appreciate it yeah it's always fun to
talk to you Abby it's great to talk to
have the ability to talk to people like
you across the universe and uh yeah
you'll get a lot of I can guarantee
you'll get a lot of views on this one
yes I know I I'm very happy to be
speaking today with my my good friend
Avi Loeb who's a professor a renowned
scientist uh the director of the Galileo
project the founder of the Galileo
project really the driving force I would
say behind so much interest nowadays in
the phenomena of of extraterrestrial uh
entities whether they be craft or
perhaps searching for hard data not just
speculation not just you know cell phone
camera reports not just professional
Skeptics this is what people want they
want hard data they want access to the
best and For Better or For Worse Avi
Harvard is the gold standard right I
mean come on Harvard is taken as a gold
standard and you were the chair of the
department for over a decade you've been
made renowned contributions to areas of
theoretical physics cosmology of
astronomy and now pivoting in later
stage of your career
to things that are exploding in interest
among the general public who pay our tax
our salary we I pay my own taxes I
almost slipped and said the public pays
of it anyway I'm not feeling good today
I've got it called but I wouldn't miss
this conversation for the world we're
talking about the Ravi Loeb and uh Avi
welcome good morning
thanks for having me it's a great
pleasure to join you and I should say
that when I uh do my work as a scientist
the fact that I belong to Harvard is
irrelevant as much as it is for a soccer
player playing for Real Madrid the other
thing I would say is that when I'm using
instruments to figure out what nature is
that's just like you using video cameras
in the world cup in soccer you know
that's what FIFA is doing it's not
relying on the players to tell them
whether there was a penalty or not it's
using video cameras and analyzing them
so you know I don't want to use humans
as scientific detectors I don't want to
subscribe to social media and listen to
how many likes I have
well it's great that you do what you do
um and what we're talking about today
and it's really speaks about your
integrity as a scientist which is that
you routinely get criticized and you get
criticized by lay people by the media uh
by you know people that are uh that want
to see you fail almost uh but you never
really shy away you've done more
podcasts than I have and uh and it's
it's really quite incredible that you
have a a knack for both the Integrity to
to face challenges but also the data to
back it up and what you're doing is to
never shy away so the most recent claim
which is met with I would say it's
almost met with Glee whenever there's a
chance very bizarre Avi that people want
a mumua to to go away they want it to be
some you know Comet some Iceberg and
maybe I mean has to we have to say maybe
it could be but there's a paper
published in nature recently and it's
not the first paper and it's not even a
theory you haven't encountered before so
I wonder if we could explore these
papers and I will I don't know do you
want me to show the nature paper first
to show the nature paper itself that It
Was Written go ahead go ahead and show
it it appeared on Thursday yeah so when
did you hear when did you first hear
about this paper Abby well a dozen
reporters from around the world ask for
my opinion the editor of nature never
asked me to referee this paper okay and
so I got a copy of it while flying back
from Switzerland I was featured in the
world Minds
forum there I had dinner with the former
head of NATO uh with the most important
architect in the world the uh Lord
Foster and with a number of very
important people and then on the flight
back I got an email from a reporter
saying there is this paper that is about
to appear in nature so that's the first
time I noticed it and then you know I
was asked by others and we can talk
about the details okay so good so let me
call up the I only have access at home
to uh to so many things that I nature
anyway just just a footnote on what said
in terms of criticism
when I came back from Switzerland I also
found in the mail the following document
that was sent to me a package from Rome
in Italy and it's actually a collection
of all the legal documents against
Galileo Galilei that was put together by
the Inquisition
and it's a this this collection is
actually dated 1907 and someone in Rome
decided to send it to me so what I'm
saying is this social phenomena of
Wishful Thinking wanting reality to be
one thing while the evidence goes
another way is not new what is new is
that it keeps persisting without us
learning lessons from the past the point
is we should adhere to evidence we
should use the laws of physics as we
know them in order to figure out what's
going out there rather than use wishful
thinking and and let me just close with
two brief examples I was once at a
thesis exam of a physics student at
Harvard and the oh the whole purpose of
the thesis was to test the popular
cosmological model of called dark matter
based on the clustering of galaxies that
was the purpose to build up a test and
then I asked the student what will
happen if we apply your test
future data and it disagrees with the
data and the answer was then it means
that I must have missed something in my
modeling because it should agree with
Lambda with the standard cosmological
model of call Dark Matter so this is one
example and then the second one was a
talk that was given a colloquium that
was given at the black hole initiative
when I was the director there by a very
prominent scientist who said that here
is the prediction of the
swampland landscape of string theory
okay for for cosmology and I said that's
great that you're making predictions so
what will happen if in the future we
have data from the cosmic Minecraft
background that disagrees with your
predictions would that rule out string
theory
and the answer was
no it will just show that my conjecture
about the swampland is incorrect String
Theory must be right and I say what have
we learned over four centuries from The
Trial of Galileo back then people were a
hundred percent sure that the sun moves
around the earth and they were willing
to prosecute Galileo for that and what
we learned from that is that debate
about the interpretation of reality is
the right way to proceed because
um eventually the truth will be revealed
now we can look at the Earth from a
distance and see that it moves around
the Sun so obviously nobody would
subscribe to the camp of the prosecutors
of Galileo yet they were 100 sure that
they're right and they put him in house
arrest
yeah and you know I often think that we
get so tied up with you know kind of
accepting the science people say oh
scientists say this so if one scientist
says one thing and another scientist
says another thing the public is kind of
left in an ambiguous superposition of
like scientists don't either scientists
don't know what they're talking about
which is very dangerous to society or
scientists you know they make their
whole living off of petty squabbles
which well well when when the data is
incomplete sometimes you can't decide
okay which side to agree with but if
someone says two plus two is five
right we all know that's wrong well Abby
hold on hold on hold on hold on at your
University there is a gentleman I think
his name is Kareem Carr and he has many
many many many uh references say two
plus two could equal five he's actually
a math graduate student at Harvard so we
should be careful because people do
accept that and it's considered uh
almost a sign of actually it's claimed
to be white supremacy to believe two
plus two equals four so let's not get
into that I don't want to get into
culture wars but let's uh let's avoid
two plus two especially at Harvard and
I'd love to talk to Kareem Someday by
the way what I want to make is that the
use of logic and the laws of physics is
recognized as the scientific method okay
and yeah and there are and you can show
that the calculation is wrong in
theoretical physics if someone uh for
example uh writes the energy equation
energy should be conserved all atoms in
the universe satisfy AI energy
conservation it's unlike interactions
between people Human Relationships do
not obey any universal laws and we know
that because there are societal laws in
the court system the legal court system
is full of cases where people violated
societal loads so if you decide and
psychologists know that if you decide
that humans will behave in one way some
of them will try to violate that so we
know from Human Relationships that laws
are not Universal but for atoms all
atoms need to satisfy energy
conservation so if this paper in nature
that we will talk about does not satisfy
energy conservation I can show that it's
wrong and there is no doubt about it
because any astronomer any physicist
will agree with me so this is not a
matter of debate whether energy
conservation was satisfied in the nature
paper or not is not a question of
opinion you can look at the equation and
see just like suppose you get a salary
and you're saying can I support my
family with this salary and all you put
into the calculation is the rent and the
heating expenses electricity expenses
and so forth but you forget to include
feeding your family then obviously you
will not be able to sustain your
lifestyle because you forgot about the
term and the same is robot energy
conservation if you're missing a term
and we will talk about which term was
missed then the reality of the situation
is that your calculation was wrong there
is no doubt about it it's not a matter
of opinion so this paper I'm going to
show it on the screen now
um I don't know if you have a copy of
the abstract and all I can show is the
abstract because
um go ahead um that's okay so it's
called
um acceleration of one eye omumua from
radioytically produced hydrogen
molecular hydrogen in uh Water Ice
so let's go through it if you have it
there
um you could you could take us through
all these different terms and I think
it's instructive for my audience which
is the brightest in the whole universe
as you know uh this audience is
incredibly technically proficient so we
can we can go as deep and nerdy we did
an hour and a half with Martin Bauer
this week on the stern gerlock
experiment um Avi so don't be afraid to
to go deep okay please it's really
straightforward here because we're
talking about things that are very
intuitive so the idea of this paper is
really simple
um we know that the uh comets uh are
often covered with water ice and so what
this paper asserts is that you start
with an iceberg made of water which we
know is common in the outer parts of
planetary systems like the solar system
and it's exposed to cosmic rays in
interstellar space as it travels to us
from another planetary system cosmic
rays keep hitting it and what they do is
dissociate water which is two hydrogen
atoms bound to an oxygen they basically
separate the hydrogen from the oxygen
when the cosmic ray goes through matter
it releases enough energy to break the
molecules of water into hydrogen and
oxygen and they claim breaking a third
of all
water molecules into hydrogen and oxygen
is very reasonable and then they go
through the calculation and show that if
a third of the iceberg is made of
hydrogen and then this object passes
near the sun when it's roughly at the
distance of the Earth from the Sun the
hydrogen would evaporate from it and
give it the push that is needed to
explain observed acceleration beyond the
Sun's gravity that that's called
outgassing that's the outgassing
usually for comets and that's the way if
you open the Encyclopedia Britannica I
comment is defined as having a comma of
gas and dust and and that is produced as
a result of the warming by sunlight if
there is water ice it goes straight from
solid into gas and together with it some
dust is released and you end up with a
coma and that is very visible because
the dust and the gas often scatter
sunlight so you see this huge tail
surrounding and coma entails surrounding
the comet that's what distinguishes a
comet from an asteroid an asteroid
doesn't have that eyes and you don't get
evaporation it's just a rock and so
that's the definition but here they say
well we suggest that in fact if you take
water ice and expose it to cosmic ray
you end up with a dark Comet which in a
way is an oxymoron because we've never
seen the dark I mean the way the comet
is defined is by having a oh my rounded
and here they say okay well there is a
comet this is the first object that came
from Interstellar space it is a comet
but what evaporates from it is hydrogen
which is transparent and to calculate
how much hydrogen comes out they
calculate the surface temperature of
this ice to demonstrate that you can get
evaporation
and they calculate the temperature of
the surface of this Iceberg just the way
you calculate the temperature of Mars
you know basically there is a balance
between the Heat delivered to the
surface from sunlight and the heat
radiated away from the surface when it's
at a given temperature and when you
balance the tool you end up with the
temperature and the temperature is just
dependent on distance
um from the Sun and there is a little
bit of energy reflected back to space
that is called Albedo and other than
that energy in equals energy out in
radiation and you end up with the
temperature so you end up that the Earth
has a temperature just around the the
freezing temperature of water and we
have a little bit of a greenhouse effect
on Earth and that's why it's habitable
and the same is true about Mars so
that's the kind of temperature that you
can get on a rock but the Albedo of the
this up so I recall you know somewhere
that uh the moon has an Albedo of like
eight percent or something meaning that
it reflects eight percent of the photons
is that about right okay
typically for asteroids the point of the
matter is they calculate the surface
temperature uh when was observed of
about 100 150 degrees Kelvin above
absolute zero by balancing hitting by
sunlight with radiation away from the
surface
that's it that's the paper and so uh one
one more thing to just summarize just
for my benefit Army
um the the notion that um what's
happening is there's hydrogen obviously
in in water so it's getting irradiated
by is it is it getting cosmic ray they
mentioned ablation is that the mechanism
that's converting then it's changing its
Albedo or is that
the cosmic rays are um changing hydrogen
to changing the water to hydrogen and
oxygen basically dissociating the water
molecules that happens over the millions
of years of interstellar travel of this
object that's what makes it in their
paper makes it different from comets
that that belong to the solar system
because they argue the Comets in the
solar system are often protected from
cosmic rays by the solar wind uh that by
itself is not a good argument because
most of the long period comets come to
us from the Oort cloud which is outside
the protection region by the solar wind
the solar wind is being stopped at a
hundred times the Earth's sun separation
that's the idiosphere and beyond that
nothing protects uh solar system Isis
from cosmic rays so in fact when we look
at long period comets that come to us we
should have seen it we haven't seen it
all the comments that we had seen had a
comma that's how they Define you go to
all the classic definitions nevertheless
they Define a dark Comet as one that was
exposed to cosmic rays for a long time
and I would say most of the long period
comets were experienced the same cosmic
rays as someone did so why and the
second point is we had seen an object
from Interstellar space that was just
like a familiar Comet it was discovered
in 2019 by Boris
yeah and and the fact that we saw that
Comet borisov means that you can't argue
that you take a regular Comet and
convert it to an invisible combat when
it it's exposed to Interstellar cosmic
rays because here is borisov it looks
like a comet so why is Boris of
different from this one and the last
point I would make is you know um
in a way defining an oxymoron a dark
comet is similar to me
um to um you know the Newspeak that was
mentioned in George Orwell's book 1984
where the party's slogan was war is
peace
ignorance is strength you know
statements that are contradictory and
saying a dark comment is a
self-contradictory but at any event they
make this point that the interstellar
comets are being affected by cosmic rays
and that's why and the point is they
just forgot one thing and as you know
their paper appeared on Thursday yeah in
nature and the same day we submitted the
paper to the astrophysical journal
letters explaining that the energy
conservation equation was not properly
treated basically the idea is you have
sunlight hitting the surface
there is radiation from the surface
that's one cooling term but another
cooling term is you need to invest
energy in dislodging the hydrogen atoms
from the lattice that is another energy
loss that you need to include and if you
increase the temperature this energy
loss goes exponentially because the
higher the temperature is the easier it
is to dislodge hydrogen atoms so once
you start raising the temperature up to
100 degrees Kelvin you get a huge
evaporation rate of the hydrogen from
the water and that carries all the
energy that comes in and then the
temperature would go down so in order to
calculate the temperature you need to
balance the heat input from sunlight
with the energy losses from radiation
and evaporation of hydrogen really
trivial they forgot to include the
cooling as a result of the energy needed
to be invested in evaporating the
hydrogen just like I talked before about
forgetting to feed your family if you're
getting a salary and claiming that will
be sufficient right so I'm showing the
paper that you submitted with is it TM
Hong
um that I'm showing on the screen now
I'm sharing the the paper uh that you
submitted so um I wanted to also ask you
one other thing which is that the you
know someone it's not that it's new to
suggest that there's some sort of
Iceberg uh type object right so so how
does this differ from I guess this paper
from a Kelly at all in 2018 and by the
way I mean you didn't Discover right you
you and there were others that that uh
astrophysicists who explain the reality
reported by observers so there was a
nature paper back in 2018 in June and
that's what led me to the suggestion
that omomoa is really weird
um and perhaps not natural perhaps
manufactured by an extraterrestrial
technological civilization that's that's
the straw that broke the camels back for
me too many
is but the one that be Kelly Marco
Michelli reported in nature was that
there is this non-gravitational
acceleration pushing it without a
cometary tale and the question was what
is pushing it and I suggested that it's
sunlight because
um the acceleration the excess push
declined inversely with distant squared
from the Sun that was a good description
of it in a smooth fashion and I said
well that's exactly how you expect
sunlight to push a very thin object and
moreover there was no Jitter in the
spin of the object and no change no
evolution in the spin the way you see it
for comets and you need if it was if it
were a comet irrespective of whether the
evaporating gas was visible or not you
had to evaporate about 10 percent a
significant fraction of the mass of the
object so it would be really difficult
to hide it and the Spitzer Space
Telescope looked very deeply around that
region and couldn't find any
carbon-based molecules whenever we have
water evaporating from the surface of a
comet there is also dust and there is
carbon based molecules so you can't just
argue oh this one is very different in
fact uh one of the authors of this paper
Daryl Seligman he wrote a review paper
about the omuamua and he wrote an email
to me last summer saying I just finished
a review paper in a very prestigious
Journal about the comet
umua and I replied what do you mean by
the comet um we both know there was no
commentary tale how can you call it a
comet and he said well I have this
theory that it had a cometary tale when
we didn't look at it and when we looked
at it it didn't have a commentary tale
and so I said that's what Einstein said
about the moon
well I said really there when you don't
look at it I mean this is just like
going to the zoo and looking at an
elephant and arguing that the elephant
is actually a generic zebra that shows
its stripes when we look away from it
and how can that be a mainstream view in
overviewing
an object that looks weird you know you
can't just say it's a comet when it's
not a comet sometimes I feel like the
child enhanced Christian Anderson's tale
um you know that said that the emperor
has no claws here the emperor is I say
it has no commentary tale and everyone
else like the adults looking at the
parade say oh yeah it's a comet with
invisible clothes within the you know
it's a dark Comet to me it's an oxymoron
I'm just one of my one of my um
listeners is asking a interesting
question Navi uh could you both be right
he's asking could the object be an
iceberg sort of towed by an
extraterrestrial and in other words
could an extraterrestrial object be
Associated affiliated with this maybe
for a source of water or something what
do you think about that idea well it's
possible it's possible I don't know
it was the size of a football field and
the argument if in if it was push Ed by
reflecting sunlight it had to be very
thin sort of like a sail or a very thin
object and actually we the same
telescope in Hawaii observed another
object that exhibited similar qualities
in September 2020 it was given the name
2020 so and it was realized a few weeks
later that this was a rocket booster
that NASA launched in 1966 and it had
thin walls made of stainless steel and
that's why there was no commentary tale
and because the walls were thin it was
pushed by reflecting sunlight so you can
imagine of course
um
something like a light sail that has a
payload attached to it perhaps but my
point is there is no evidence for the
payload okay what we see is we we can't
we don't have an image of the object it
would have been nice to have one but
given the data that we have one simple
explanation is that it's being pushed by
sunlight and you may ask where would
such an object come from and it could be
just Space trash I wrote a paper that
was published two weeks ago actually
talking about
Dyson spheres so Freeman Dyson 60 years
ago suggested the idea that a very
Advanced technological civilization
might build a megastructure around its
host stuff it was my first guest on the
podcast uh Avi oh really really
um anyway I always admired him I met him
personally for many years at the
Princeton The Institute for advanced
study where I was a postdoc that's where
I learned astrophysics anyway so his
suggestion was that an advanced
civilization will try to harvest much
more energy from its hot star than we do
you know even with our plans for clean
energy at best we can harvest the energy
intercepting with the Earth but he was
thinking you know surrounding the star
with some kind of a sphere and it could
be made made of tiles that are basically
light sales that's what Robert forward
they suggest this variant on dice idea
basically having tiles such that the
radiation pressure outputs is balanced
by gravity inwards so you have those
hovering above the stars and so at any
event if the civilization is using a
Dyson Sphere for a while eventually it
might migrate away especially when the
star evolves and if it leaves the the
structure behind the structure could be
torn apart by impacts of asteroids or
actually if it's made of types of solar
cells you know when the star evolves
when the sun will brighten up it will
push away because for the same mass it
will have much higher Luminosity so it
will push away all these tiles and they
can become Interstellar objects and one
of them may have been normal so it could
be pieces of a broken Dyson Sphere so
that's an example for Space trash that
could lead to very thin objects that you
know pollute space and every now and
they accelerate with that type of space
trash accelerate um you know unusually
well it will it will because it's thin
all you need for it to exhibit excess
push away from the Sun is for it to be
thin so that its area per unit mass will
be high and that's what the 2020 so
which was the rocket booster from NASA
yeah and that's what it was and it
showed that phenomena so that's what I
was suggesting that uh or more and more
was thin and therefore pushed away we
don't know what the origin of it and
what was it designed for
um I should another footnote I should
mention that there was a paper that I've
written with the director of aaro at the
Pentagon there is an organization
collecting all the data about
unidentified aerial phenomena
and we had a draft together with him his
name is Sean Kirkpatrick which got a lot
of attention just because the Pentagon
is collaborating with a scientist from a
an ivy league university
at any event in that paper which was not
yet submitted because it's under review
um
um in that paper we
um mentioned in the introduction the
possibility that uh you can have a
Mothership that releases a lot of small
probes and the reason I came across this
idea is because
shared the same distance of closest
approach in the same speed as an
Interstellar meteor that was discovered
seven months before it in March 2017 and
it was detected by you the U.S
government and put in the meteor catalog
and together with my student Amir siraj
we identified it as moving too fast to
be bound to the Sun so we identified it
as an Interstellar meteor of very high
material strength because it burned up
in the lower atmosphere of the Earth
this was the second interest parameter
we discovered another one from 2014 but
what was special about the 2017 one is
that it shared the same distance at
closest approach to the sun and the same
speed at that distance
did and so I thought to myself oh let's
check the orbit because maybe it was
released maybe it's a fragment either
naturally broken off a piece broken off
or
it was purposely released as like the
dandelion seeds you know like if you
have a a large Mothership releasing
probes into the habitable zone but it
turns out that when you map the orbit
they couldn't have come from the same
place and then but that led me to
suggest a possible scenario of course
the purpose of any extraterrestrial
technological Gadget depends on what the
senders wanted to use it for or it could
be just Space trash you know we when you
go to the ocean you find a lot of
plastic trash and it indicates that
there are there is a technological
civilization out there in fact the mass
of this trash will exceed the mass of of
fish in the oceans by 2050 if we don't
stop throwing trash into the ocean but
that a human human generated trash not
an extraterrestrial trash no this one is
human but if if you're asking if there
is an extraterrestrial uh equipment in
the ocean that's what we're going to
find out and we can talk about it before
that's the first Interstellar meteor
we're trying we will try uh to go there
to the explosion side of that meteor and
find the relics from it in order to
analyze their composition and figure out
whether it was a spacecraft actually
because it has material strength tougher
than iron we can talk about it yeah
we'll talk about I'm throwing that paper
on the screen your paper from August
2022 with uh Amir and Tim
um but uh when you talk about the
confidence interval and apologies we're
talking with Avi Loeb uh professor of
astronomy at Harvard University
um Brian Keating not feeling 100 great
today but I could not miss my
opportunity to share with you my
audience this conversation with a
renowned friend and and uh thinker oh
you talk about the probability of it not
being uh extra solar and you say it's
99.99 yes five nines percent
um is there really no you know one in a
million uh probably like these objects
could they not be scattered from the
Oort cloud and some violent collisions
from some interactions from local local
Stellar systems and so forth is it
really true that we have I mean I have
these meteorites here which I give away
to my audience uh when they sign up for
my mailing list at Brian keating.com
list I'll put that up on the screen uh
so if you have a uh if you have a edu
address you win one of these chunks of
this looks like omuamua doesn't it
umized version because the Momo was the
size of a football field
that's right I couldn't fit that here
you know our budget at UCSD is not as
large as as Harvard but uh is it really
so hard to get an object from another
solar system into our solar system can
you explain that well let's talk about
the first Interstellar meteor which was
the first object from outside the solar
system ever discovered by humans and it
was detected by the US government as you
mentioned in 2014 January 8th uh and
they just cataloged it NASA put it in a
catalog of meteor so the US government
monitors the atmosphere uh you know for
ballistic missiles uh as a national
security matter and every now and then
they see an object coming from out there
and colliding with Earth uh it's a
meteor it's a rock usually from the
solar system in fact every year there is
a rock the size of a person uh colliding
with Earth every year that releases as
much energy as the Hiroshima atomic bomb
wow so we get an atomic explosion every
year we don't hear about about it but
because it happens 30 kilometers above
the ocean surface most likely above the
ocean because it the oceans cover most
of the earth is 70 but it doesn't cause
much damage it's such an elevation
um and we just don't hear about it but
the US government knows about it and
they basically catalog meteors that they
see from the fireball that is created as
a result of the friction of this object
with the air
uh so they do catalog them and we found
this meteor from 2014 that moved too
fast to be bound to the Sun and in fact
we calculated how how fast it was moving
outside the solar system before it
entered the solar system it was moving
at 60 more than 60 kilometers per second
which is faster than 95 percent of all
the stars in the vicinity of the Sun
so it was moving so fast outside the
solar system that you couldn't get it to
move that fast as a result of an
interaction with an old Cloud object or
it wasn't even moving close to any of
the planets in the solar system and a
passage of another star at a large
separation would not give it much of a
kick in order to get a kick of you know
other 60 kilometers per second it really
needs to interact with a star even
closer than the separation of the earth
from the sun Maybe by a factor of four
or so so it really was extremely close
to a star which is a very unlikely event
and so it was moving too fast uh to be
bound to the Sun and even too fast to be
associated with any of the nearby Stars
95 percent of all stars and the question
is what was it and and of course when we
submitted our paper for public
application in 2019 saying this is the
first Interstellar object it predated
the omuamua by almost four years the
referees in the astrophysical journal
rejected the paper they said we don't
believe the US government and I thought
to myself how can that be the case if if
they are trying to figure out whether a
ballistic missile will hit Boston or New
York City they must have very good
sensors they can't get it wrong and um I
basically reached out to people in in
over the National Security Fence and
eventually it was a person in the White
House that mediated the release of
information and there was a letter sent
to NASA by the U.S space command under
the Department of Defense stating at the
99.99 that the error Bars were small
enough that this object definitely at
the 99.99
came from outside the solar system
that's it that it must have been the
error budget was extremely small and
then our paper was accepted for
publication and the U.S the US
government also released the light curve
of the Fireball and moreover additional
data on this meteor and that allowed us
to calculate that it actually exploded
10 kilometers above the ocean surface
and that's very low in the atmosphere
compared to this I was mentioning before
so that meant that it there was an
extremely uh high stress exerted on the
surface of the object because it moved
very fast
and it was also uh it experienced a
density of air that is quite high at the
bottom of the atmosphere and we
calculated that the material strength of
this object must have been 10 times
higher than any other object in the
catalog of 273 of them that the
government compiled so why would the
first Interstellar meteor be the
toughest of all the space rocks ever
detected by this by these sensors and uh
the there are two possibilities either
it originated from a system very
different in the solar system so even in
the solar system the toughest meteors
are made of iron they are called iron
meteorites yep that's where you'll get
it from a million list yeah yeah
toughest and this one was 10 times
tougher in material strength the
question is what was it made of and of
course it could have arrived from some
natural source like for example an
exploding star or two neutron stars
colliding something that we've never
imagined producing Interstellar objects
or it may be an artificial alloy made of
stainless steel once again you know like
a spacecraft and the only way to figure
out is not to argue about it on Twitter
the way some people do I don't have any
account on social media as I said and I
don't want to argue I just follow the
scientific method you know I just want
to go there and collect fragments and
then examine their composition it's
straightforward that's what the kid
would do if you have a question you go
and check check it test it and so I said
we want to go there after the paper was
accepted for publication and then soon
afterwards a person from the general
public came forward and said
on a zoom meeting he said on a zoom call
he said
you have it one and a half million
dollars necessary to to fund Expedition
here it is go ahead okay so I didn't do
any fundraising and this person will
come with us actually on the Expedition
um his name is Charles hoskinson uh and
he was very generous and that's the way
I raised funding also for the Galileo
project separate from the Expedition I
got them a few million dollars this way
and you know it's nice I mean you you
you're too uh you're too steel to your
too uh modest RV but I'll have to tune
your horn a little bit here so you know
one thing that strikes me about the
research that you do and the and the
approach to the scientific method that
you Endeavor to to uphold and why I like
talking to you so much
is that you're doing stuff that a is
incredibly intellectually stimulating
you're trying to do it be with Integrity
you're also trying to do it for the
benefit of the public and I think a lot
of what we do is kind of cloistered away
uh and part of the reason I love doing
this YouTube channel aside from the fact
I get to talk to the most brilliant
people on earth
um including you know this week alone
I'm gonna have a conversation with the
new super conductor you think it's it's
controversial Avi talking about imagine
you announced a room temperature
superconductor uh so I'm talking to uh
some of the critics of that paper
as well so anyway
but the last thing is that you do it for
the benefit of the public meaning that
these Endeavors are meant to
um to maybe reduce the cost to the
public of things like
um a huge NASA study uh which is being
led by our mutual friend David spurgle
uh to study the properties of
extraterrestrial data perhaps or
unidentified aerial phenomena more
precisely but this Mission you point out
in this paper from last year is about
you know one percent or maybe less of
the bennu mission right so yeah going to
Earth it's it's like Elon Musk you know
who uh is is so ingenious but you know
he wants to go to Mars and live out his
days on Mars and you know our mutual
friend Martin Rhys says you know I hope
you don't die on impact on Mars to Elon
but
isn't it much more likely to find a
habitable zone on Earth than to go to
Mars as cool as that would be and I'm
sure I would love to take the 20 000th
ride to Mars but um but you're doing
this for the benefit of the public this
is not a public taxpayers right this is
not some international team this is you
guys and some Speedos going down to New
Guinea so yeah I I want to commend you
for that thank you I mean um I don't see
myself and even though I'm a member of
the ivy league I don't see myself very
different than any common person any
person on the street because I grew up
on a farm you know I used to collect
eggs every afternoon I was connected to
Nature I'm not trying to impress people
uh I bet if I see the public interested
in this subject and the government is
interested in this subject then how can
the scientific Community shy away from
it how can it be uh arguing that you
know it's too risky it will be a waste
of taxpayers money when the taxpayers
want it right and so at the same time
you know we are spending billions of
dollars in the search for dark matter
the Large Hadron Collider didn't find
supersymmetry and you know that's not
considered an extraordinary claim but
that something like us exists or existed
around the planet like the Earth
moving around the star like the sun is
considered an extraordinary claim and I
say that is arrogant it's as arrogant as
saying I don't care about the public
opinion there are more than 60 percent
of American citizens that believe in
express your life
this is more than the number of people
believing in God and I would also argue
that you know most of the stars from
billions of years before the Sun so we
should just look out and check if there
are any packages in our mailbox and in
the past you know I get hostility also
from the seti community which is very
surprising to me because what I'm doing
is looking for techno signatures which
is what they're doing but in a different
way so they are looking for radio
signals for 70 years haven't found
anything it's just like waiting for a
phone call at home and there may not be
anyone calling you at the time that you
are waiting for it I say let's look at
our mailbox at our backyard or any
packages that arrive because you even if
the senders are not alive anymore even
if their star burned up their Planet you
know it's possible the packages arrive
to us and we can learn about them yeah
yeah yeah so as you said last time
you're on with Gary Nolan uh well you
know I have a link to that on the on the
show you've discussed this many times
but you had a great line you said the
sky is not classified
and the ocean is that class well parts
of the ocean in our classroom but the
ocean's not qualified
actually I should also say that you know
when you go to your backyard what my
colleagues are doing with respect to a
Momoa is saying oh we've been to our
backyard we know that it's full of rocks
and I say well if an object arrived to
our backyard we all agree that it
arrived from outside of our backyard
that's what an Interstellar object is
you know maybe it's a tennis ball that
was thrown by a neighbor why would you
assume that all the objects that come
from the street are rocks of the type
that you find in your backyard and you
know we know already that most of this
the matter in the universe is not what
we find in in in in our solar system
most of the matter is dark we don't know
what it's made of we call it dark matter
we learned already that that the solar
system is not representative of the
universe so why would we argue that any
Interstellar object must be a rock even
if it looks different than all the Rocks
we had seen in the solar system that's
just common sense and what I find is
that common sense is not common so on
the one hand I see people from Academia
attacking a very simple you know
approach that uses the scientific method
basically trying to collect evidence
they have a problem with that they say
actually culinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and how would you
get evidence if you're not searching
that's my point I say extraordinary
evidence requires extraordinary funding
and what happens is that they don't fund
any research in that direction and
therefore they say there is no evidence
it's as if you would say uh the claim
that the dark matter is the lightest
supersymmetric particle is extraordinary
and we don't have evidence for that so
we should not explore it that's not what
the mainstream of physics did it said
this is a statement worth putting
billions of dollars to testing and then
they didn't and then they didn't find it
and nobody says that was a waste of
money why because that's the way science
is done at the Frontiers you're
exploring the unknown and you can't just
say that the lightest supersymmetric
particle is an extraordinary claim that
requires extraordinary evidence because
to find the evidence you need to put in
billions of dollars so that's what's
happening in the context of
technological objects from extra
Threshers organization so nobody is
willing to put the money except when I
come forward with a research plan then
wealthy individuals come forward and say
here is the money because they see you
know that this is the the way the path
for us to uh expand our scientific
knowledge yeah and you know it's it's
just
straightforward I don't see why people
no no it's true and then and one thing I
love is that you're you're not even shy
to to you know kind of stimulate
discussion I don't think you pick fights
I think you you stimulate discussion
even with colleagues down the hall at
Harvard and I've I've you and I talked
about this I think the first or second
time you're on the podcast and you've
been gracious enough to come on multiple
times but your friend Cameron bafan and
he and I had conversations and we can
bring up stuff and that's the way
science should be done science isn't
done by debates and by press releases
um I can't help because I do want to
take a couple questions before my voice
gives out for my audience uh but before
I do that I'm going to ask you a
question you have your choice Hashem God
he tells you Avi pick one
or this meteorite which one would you
rather have the actual proof or evidence
that uh Alien civilizations
technological civilizations exist well
obviously the meteorite because I can go
there and study it you see I'm is not
around anymore if I had a close-up
photograph of that's what I mean yeah so
a closer photograph or it proves its
actual like a spaceship or that the
meteorite is a space junk from another
I'm I'm a practical person I don't
really imagine uh well if we had an
opportunity to go to a Momo obviously
I'll do that but uh right now the best
way to proceed is to check what this
meteor was like uh of course we can find
more objects like we have a dating app
which is called the Vera Rubin
Observatory that will have a survey of
the sky with 3.2 billion pixel camera in
a year or so and it will survey the
um the the southern Sky every four days
and uh presumably we'll find more
objects like so we can get close to them
take a observe them with the web
telescope which is about a million miles
away from Earth so we will see the
object from two directions from
telescopes on Earth and from the web
telescope up and that would allow us to
pin down the trajectory in three
dimensions very precisely and figure out
whether there is some propulsion or
whether it's just the trajectory is
shaped just by the Sun's gravity that
would be a great benefit so that there
are lots of things to do in the future
and you know I was asked by a podcaster
just a few days ago uh in a podcast
called unheard
u-n-h-e-r-d we can advertise competitors
podcasts here Avi do not yeah I'm just
advertising one question the question
was we hear from many of your colleagues
that they are a hundred percent sure
that omuamua was not and
extraterrestrial technological Relic and
I said well that's a reflection on them
not on because there were people during
the days of Galileo also 100 sure that
the sun moves around the earth the point
is when you have incomplete data you
cannot be sure uh only Believers are a
hundred percent sure right scientists
with partial data are never sure so if
you want to follow the scientific method
all you say is I want better data in
order to figure it out out of curiosity
being like a child you know we uh if we
don't ask those questions we basically
broadcast worldwide that we lost our
childhood curiosity yeah and then
sometimes they're too childish sometimes
they're too childlike they they want to
take their toys and go home and and they
want to be jealous and Petty but uh so
Avi we have a few minutes left I've got
a ton of questions 700 questions here
but I only ask you we'll do a rapid fire
uh Rock SD is asking
um is it significant that of all the
planets in our solar system that both
omuamua and this meteorite came to the
Earth instead of say Jupiter
oh no then okay it depends on the
trajectory so um if you assume that um
it came on a random trajectory uh there
should be an object like it every year
coming into the orbit of the Earth
around the Sun so it's really common
however you can reduce the number of
objects by a factor of uh 10 to the 10
billion or so if you imagine uh that
they were targeting the habitable zone
so if they were sent into the habitable
region where the Earth moves around the
Sun uh then there are many fewer by 10
billion and we don't know uh so we just
need better statistics and hopefully the
very Rubin Observatory will give us more
examples so
um someone's asking about jwst as
anything jwst can do with regard to
searching for these objects or similar
to search because the web telescope has
a very small field of view of all the
five arc minutes about the tenth of a of
a degree and so it's a very a small View
and these objects you need to to look at
the entire sky and also find one of them
and so in combination with the Vera
Rubin Observatory that will survey the
sky uh that could alert the web
telescope to an existing object and then
it's just like having two eyes you can
gauge distance much better the reason we
have two eyes is so that we can have
three-dimensional uh calibration of the
threat that is in front of us that
allows us to survive so um in in the
same way web telescope and earth-based
Telescope could figure the distance and
very precisely to an an object like
right okay next question toe lab asks
okay this change in speed of a mumua was
small compared to a typical Comet moving
in an elliptical orbit I guess my
question is
um do we see comments that just move I
mean we know that our comments that have
a commentary tale do they ever exhibit
strange accelerations comparable yeah
this is coming from the rocket effect
that when it's the same effect that is
pushing Rockets or jet planes basically
airplanes and I once did a calculation
on a fly they throw back material so
that it pushes the Jet Plane forward
that's basically what happens and the
same is true about rockets and you need
to carry the fuel with you and comet is
exactly the same thing it has water ice
on the surface it evaporates as a result
of the warming by sunlight and then it
pushes the comet in away from the Sun
and yes we do see that for small enough
so the force is proportional to the
surface area of the Comet and then the
acceleration is the force divided by the
mass so the mass goes like the volume of
the Comet and therefore the area to
volume a ratio dictates how much it's
accelerated so
in other words the acceleration is
bigger for smaller objects it it's
inversely proportional to the size of
the Comet so for small comets you can
get much more acceleration and and it's
noticeable for very big cores you don't
get that and then so that is observed
for comets and that's the way they they
behave
um and um or more and more exhibited the
same kind of an acceleration except
there was no commentary tail
and we look at things um someone's
asking Brian Kelly's a friend of the
show I was asking about uh the Pioneer
space anomaly things like that are those
you know I guess my question would be we
know cosmic rays exist and we know that
you know these light sales can exist do
we have any evidence that light sales
could be damaged or you know affected by
in other words could there be sort of a
hybrid solution a light sale
cosmic rays could could these interact
in some way that could degrade the
performance or change trajectory and do
certain such things yeah we we actually
in the original paper suggesting that
it's a very thin object
we actually made an estimate what is the
impact of either cosmic rays or
Interstellar
particles uh dust particles gas
particles on it and we concluded that
it's quite minimal I mean it will not
destroy the object simply because the
interstellar medium is so dilute I mean
obviously you can have holes in the sale
as a result of dust particles passing
through but it will not destroy the
entire cell simply because the medium is
very rarefied out there
that's right so Avi I want to just
conclude
um by well uh asking you if you had to
do what we call a steel man if you had
to give your best reproduction of the
criticism against you what do you think
is the best critique of the omumua as
extraterrestrial
technology what do you think is the best
in your estimation of all the critiques
yeah so I would argue that uh well first
of all this paper in nature that
appeared a few days ago in the abstract
says explicitly that past explanations
of the uh non-gravitational acceleration
in the form of a hydrogen Iceberg
nitrogen Iceberg Dust Bunny are not
valid the paper admits that and now we
showed also that what the paper suggests
the hydrogen water iceberg is also not
valid because of energy conservation so
all of these have issues uh all of the
explanations uh and if you wanted to
explain uh what was observed I would
argue maybe the data was wrong the
observation uh reported results that are
not valid in the sense that when people
analyze the trajectory they forgot to
compensate for some error in the
measurement so if I had to guess my
guess would be that the original nature
paper if you don't want to admit that
was a very thin object that the original
nature paper from 2018 by micheli uh was
wrong simply they uh the data that they
analyzed was miscalculated there was
something off and they inferred a
non-gravitational acceleration but it
wasn't in reality it wasn't there that
would be the simplest way to resolve it
without any commentary Tale
hmm very good well Avi I want to thank
you so much apologize for my uh my voice
but uh as I said I couldn't miss it for
the world to have a chance or out of
this world to have a chance to chat with
you you're always such a gracious guest
and uh one of the favorites of my
audience which is growing uh thanks to
having guests Like You on the podcast uh
the into the impossible podcast going
over a hundred thousand viewers I can't
believe it or a hundred thousand
subscribers just on YouTube and then
we've got another 50 or 60 000 elsewhere
but Avi I want to thank you so much
reminder check out Galileo project on
Twitter check them out on their website
you can uh support their research which
is incredibly important you can respond
to comments and stuff and articles I put
them up they're all in the show notes
for the from YouTube and uh subscribe to
my mailing list Brian keating.com list
and you two may win a miniature chunk of
a muamu which sticks to my cell phone
magnitude there it is here it is
cruising through this over system thank
you Brian if we find something in the
Pacific Ocean I'll be glad to see you
again and even give you a souvenir from
there that'll be great I'm gonna send
you as uh into the impossible Speedo
that you can wear while you're swimming
uh through the ocean there obviously
thank you my friend goodbye
thanks for having me bye-bye